[Música]
[Aplausos]
eres feminista
es una de las primeras preguntas que de
repente me hacen cuando intento
descender el lenguaje incluyente
o cuando me pasa en un documento y me
dicen sugiere algo lenguaje incluyente
un día un jefe me puso gretel y sus
rollos es enteros
[Música]
eres feminista me preguntan cuando
suelta en un chiste que para mí es
misógino y para mi misógino es que
denosta el cuerpo de las mujeres que los
expone
que hace que la gente se burle de alguna
discapacidad o por su raza o por su
credo o por su condición social y se
supone que tiene que ser chistoso y que
a mí no me lo parece
y es que tengo que hacer un recuento un
recuento generacional
porque la pregunta es impertinente
dice nuria varela en su libro feminismo
para principiantes hagan un ejemplo en
una reunión social o familiar suerte en
la palabra
y si es feminismo y la gente dice como
si hubiera dicho soy terrorista en una
cosa así espantoso horrible sin saber de
dónde vengo con qué se mastica entonces
yo visibilizó dos partes esa primera
falta de reconocimiento histórico que
tenemos pues de más de trescientos
siglos en donde las mujeres han estado
de una manera muy intensa visibilizando
el tema y poniéndolo en la mesa del
debate pero porque incómoda porque creen
ustedes que incómoda
bueno pues incómoda porque cuestiona un
orden establecido un orden establecido
que está muy bien establecido
y que beneficia evidentemente a quienes
lo establecieron
es una teoría política es una teoría de
justicia es una teoría que pone hincapié
en todas esas desigualdades que de
manera histórica insisto han estado las
mujeres las mujeres que ya saltamos a la
escena pública pero que durante mucho
tiempo estuvimos solamente en el ámbito
privado realizando ese tipo de
actividades que la sociedad nos impone
porque además la sociedad es bien
crítica con las mujeres o sea la
sociedad espera que las mujeres hagan
algo en específico y que además lo hagan
bien y claro también espera eso de los
hombres pero con nosotras de repente
siento que hasta nos cargan la mano
eso me lleva a la reflexión y me lleva a
pensar que yo soy una mujer privilegiada
y digo soy una mujer privilegiada porque
tuve la oportunidad de estudiar la
carrera que yo decidí y eso lo puedo
considerar como un privilegio
y para mí es un privilegio porque no es
la misma carrera que estudió mi madre o
que estudió mi padre y que sin embargo
me dieron la posibilidad de estudiar lo
que yo quisiera que en este caso fue
comunicación pero esa posibilidad no la
tuvo mi abuela mi abuela que sabía leer
y escribir pero que no tuvo la
posibilidad mi abuela angelita de
estudiar una carrera universitaria esa
posibilidad que ya la tuvo mi mamá y ya
la tuvo mi mamá porque mi abuela
angelita se trajo a mi mamá a la capital
y la inscribió en la escuela de
enfermería
esa carrera que he dicho sea de paso
todavía algunos años estaba muy
catalogada como una carrera solamente
para las mujeres porque ese es otro tema
las mujeres en lo público cuidamos y las
mujeres en lo privado cuidamos cuidamos
a las personas enfermas cuidamos a los
menores cuidamos a las personas con
discapacidad cuidamos a lanzar a los
adolescentes cuidamos a todo el mundo
cuidamos las mujeres tenemos ese don de
cuidar
pero regreso al término de la educación
yo tuve la oportunidad de estudiar mi
madre ya tuvo la oportunidad de estudiar
que además estudió después una
licenciatura ya conmigo a cuestas y con
mi hermana también y bueno mi hija a mi
hija adolescente que evidentemente
seguramente tendrá la oportunidad de
estudiar la carrera que ella decida y
pinta para artistas y digo que soy
afortunada porque yo tengo la
posibilidad o en su momento tuve la
posibilidad de casarme con quien yo
decidí digo que elegí mal eso es otra
cosa pero tuve esa posibilidad
eso mi abuela esta oportunidad mi abuela
no la tuvo y no la tuvo porque
finalmente bueno
se casó con mi abuelo tuvo 12 partos mi
mamá solamente tuvo 2 yo solamente tuve
2 y vayan ustedes a saber si mi hija
decida o no decida
tener bebés esto quiere decir que estoy
en una generación viva de cuatro
generaciones que evidentemente hemos
visto cómo ha sido progresivo de manera
agigantada en algunos aspectos pero de
manera muy lenta en otros por ejemplo
con los métodos anticonceptivos esos
métodos que además haciendo un
paréntesis siempre esa industria
farmacéutica que pone el ojo así en el
cuerpo de las mujeres
porque las mujeres tenemos el parche
anticonceptivo tenemos el diu tenemos el
implantes intrauterino y tenemos
inyecciones y tenemos la píldora del día
siguiente y tenemos y tenemos y tenemos
y tenemos
y nosotros podemos partir una vez al año
[Música]
los hombres tienen un solo método
anticonceptivo digamos el más conocido y
podrían embarazar una mujer diaria
y algunos presumiendo dicen que estabas
entonces para quien tendrían que ir
dirigidos los métodos anticonceptivos
y retomo soy una mujer privilegiada
porque puedo viajar a donde yo quiera
sin pedirle el consentimiento a mi
pareja
y puedo
votar circunstancia evidentemente es
sumamente importante
y digo importante porque mi abuela nunca
pudo votar y aunque mi madre por
supuesto ya pudo hacerlo a mí me brinca
y me pone la piel de gallina a pensar
precisamente insisto que hay
generaciones vivas que han podido palpar
y que han podido agradecer porque de eso
va el tema de feminismo agradecer a esas
generaciones y estas olas del feminismo
que durante muchos años insisto han
visibilizado el tema
tenemos una agenda pendientes y porque
además el feminismo es una palabra que
cada vez es más recurrente a veces me da
la impresión que no termina de
consolidarse que no termina de
entenderse pero finalmente nos
corresponde a esta generación tomar la
estafeta de todas esas mujeres que
durante tantos años han estado pugnando
por los derechos a la salud por los
derechos laborales por los derechos de
nuestro cuerpo tan importantes por el
derecho al voto y por derecho a una vida
en paz
la agenda evidentemente es muy ambiciosa
pero él
en todo caso el feminismo es una teoría
política y una teoría social que llegó
para quedarse porque saben que el
feminismo lo cambia todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]